hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
gonna be checking out the official
Deadpool trailer the teaser trailer
number one I got to bed super late and
then I woke up for 20 minutes because I
needed to go to the bathroom number two
and then I saw my comments that this
teaser trailer was dropped so off of a
couple hours of sleep let's do this
in a world divided by fear one man must
stand alone against the forces of
darkness from the studio that
inexplicably sodas [ __ ] mouths shut
the first time Deadpool so get ready to
blow out your collective sphincters cuz
my trailer is coming tomorrow super
short but I [ __ ] love it I mean that
teaser trailer you already get a good
tone and sense of what kind of character
this is but I like how they're
establishing that he's probably gonna be
breaking the fourth wall that he's gonna
be self-aware there's gonna be satire I
normally don't like teaser trailers to
trailers because usually just 15 seconds
of the official trailer but that was
like the best teaser trailer to a
trailer I've seen in a while you bet
your ass I'm gonna be there for the
official trailer tomorrow anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope because if we get enough
followers we can get even more product
placement
what up Johnson love your videos you
always have hot woman by your side not
today I am masturbating solo what's your
secret
well all you got to do is get a youtube
channel and convince women that by
having them come on your channel it'll
benefit them in some way
that simple woman are easy to fall for
[ __ ] like that can I get a shout-out for
the simple fact my name is pronounced
like Superman's father's name but the
spelling is jar not jor alright dude
what up Johnson that's what I say to
myself every morning when I sat here on
this chair I was like all right Ryan
what are we gonna do you got to make
sure to be focused you got to make sure
you're having a good time when you watch
this trailer whatup Johnson as long as
the Johnson downstairs is good that's
where all my confidence comes from 6
inches its average I know but it makes
me feel calm